isabel
no ingredient ingrid i knew it was an
eye
okay
all right ingrid yes ingrid where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i grew up i was born in downtown l.a
at the red cross hospital uh but i grew
up in uh
what we call people union by um
venice and in vermont and then i moved
to south central when i was nine
i saw centuries
most of my childhood until i was 18
i had my first beer well i used to drink
with my dad as
as a as a little uh uh i was like uh
seven my dad was mad alcoholic he was
mad alcoholic man
he would give me beer and i would drink
beer and everything
and then um we moved to south central
and i i stopped drinking beer and
everything i know his beer is not like
that strong but
when you got practices i would do and
everything and
you know people do witchcraft and
everything so things like that
and then um uh
i drank my first beer because i didn't
want to grow up man i don't want to grow
up i i want i want to stay young and i
don't want to go to 6th grade i was like
nah nah nah
i don't want to be with those kids they
put makeup on they only talk about sex
and i don't i don't even got boobs i
don't even
i just i just wanted to be a kid you
know
and then um i had my first beer i
started disney school that's when i
started messing up because i didn't want
to go to school i didn't want to go to
school
i felt like i was getting dumber for
some reason and
um and only one teacher inspired me a
lot
mr brown be able to teach me words
and and i have i have real
strong difficulties uh communicating
with people
uh unless i'm relaxed with a beer um i'm
really i tried
mushrooms acid um crack
math and but i can only i i'm
it's not my thing but beer yeah it's
like like um
i started slowly i started teaching
school
started messing up i started like well
not being too smart
you know not making wise choices you
know in the ghetto you know
how was your childhood my childhood was
you know i'm the second oldest out of
seven
kids you know we were poor and
everything we're living on welfare
uh my dad really didn't help us so much
he would take it away from us
he would take the money and and make us
suffer you know and
live off of beans and rice some and then
um
sometimes uh around the seventh grade
like sometimes we never have electricity
but
but that's pretty smart i mean even
though he's evil
um he will hook up the electricity
somehow i don't know he would do the
wiring
that's dangerous you know and sometimes
we only had cold water
and we just you know enough to get by
you know and everything then my pet my
foes got divorced
when i was uh 13 and everything
and then i started drinking at family
gatherings a little bit more
a little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
to relax because i got a lot of anxiety
i got mental illness
i got schizophrenia i got anxiety i got
insomnia
i got depression i was suicidal a lot
for like about like a lot of my years
because i said man i'm poor man i want
to succeed and i'm not the smartest one
so how about how would i gather this how
would i build up the skill
to work and succeed in life and take my
family out to ghetto
and and i just saw i always looked up to
my brother he's my other brother
we had seven kids you know and he would
inspire me like because he was always
good at school always good at sports
and things like that but i i don't know
i'm just mental i just
i i think i got dyslexia i got too many
mental illnesses
how far do you go in school i i went all
the way to 11th grade
but um i really it was it was a
continuation school
and how serious did your suicide
attempts get
i i jumped a third story building
i tried to get a gun i tried uh overdose
i just bled off my air blew my i think
my eardrum blew and i bled and i still
survived
uh then i got over it
and uh
i i would drink drink drink drink drink
drink drink
that was my day this my mom i don't know
she
if she um enabled me or not
but um i would drink and i would say mom
this is who i am
i like to drink and um
uh i would just drink the whole day you
know just
uh out of depression and so i could just
anxiety was so strong that i needed
something to relax i didn't need an
upper like math
i was going to be like you know like you
know tripping
i needed something to relax to relax to
relax to relax
and i didn't get my medication until i
was like
i don't remember because i forgot i got
i got a lot of mental
design you're not gonna believe me but i
got like uh i forget things a lot i
forget i forget
a lot of things i i forget i just forget
um and um
so anyways i would drink drink drink
drink drink until i got kicked out
i got kicked out i got kicked out and
i met this this this homeless person
this um in south central in the homeless
shelter
i i was walking and trying to get a
pickle and he came out of nowhere
and then i i didn't want to be alone you
know
and that's not in the street uh so we
just kind of like clicked and everything
and we became together he took me to his
family's house i would drink drink drink
and he would smoke smoke
and things like that but that that was
us you know and i fell in love with him
or whatever and
he got me pregnant and
my baby was my motivation to to become a
better person
but i i always thought how am i going to
teach her things if i don't know
anything
you know and and i said
they told me you wanted an abortion i
left i left i said no i don't believe in
those things
and i had my baby and i was sober but
then i just got
so like desperate to start drinking
again
and then dcfs came in i think one of the
neighbors called them
uh and they they
they took it away from me and she was
adopted for about like almost
only for about a month because i fought
the case i did the i did the classes i
did the therapy
i went to rehab uh i was doing my best
but
the the addiction is a little too strong
you know and i know you just beer but
i never get wild with beer i never like
to get violent uh
i never i don't believe that beer makes
you forget
maybe it does i don't know does that
forget you know
um but um
it wasn't meant to be and i and my
brother thank god he
sees somebody in life and then he took
um
he got the rights to my daughter
so your brother raised your your
daughter i was still around
um illegally because i i wasn't a lot of
situations or anything but i was
sneaking to the house say oh you know
i'll visit her
and uh i even prostituted this to buy
her
things you know and things i tried it
but i don't i don't like it i didn't
process twitter like two times three
times
and um and um
uh she got taken away from me and then
um
i i couldn't be in the house because
that it's a lot of family issues
with my sisters they don't like me i
don't like them
except my brother you know and then i
just got to
to to like i guess the boiling point
that that i couldn't be in the house
like it was like no you can't be here
but anyways throughout that time
throughout the whole um
time i've been homeless about 10 years
10 years yeah the first time i was
homeless i was 15 years old
and uh we lost we lost our our house
and um we went to a family member's
house and she kicked me out because
uh she didn't like me or whatever and i
went to sleep in hollywood
and um and i tried to i i i even tried
to go sleep by the museum you know uh
exposition part and everything um but
i said nah i gotta break them up too you
know i'm gonna get raped or something
uh something's gonna happen to me i
should probably go back home and beg
them and
and then they let me back in or whatever
so what are your questions so
you have just the one daughter i just
have one daughter i don't have more kids
i don't want
i don't want i don't want them in the
ghetto
how did you end up on skid row let's get
roll
ah skid row skid row i don't remember
but
um i just uh we'll go on the bus
just to think or you know drink and then
um
somehow i ended up in skid row i think i
was like 23 and i
slept there i sometimes i i i even uh
i think i was going kind of crazy you
know and not because of the drugs
because i could i only smoked a few
times i smell crack
and but i would drink drink drink and i
don't i don't know i just
depression demonic forces
and things like that you know and and um
i was raised in the church you know
so i believe in the prophecy
and i said i am i left behind lord
am i left behind no forgive me lord
and i even did naked lady and everything
i took off my clothes but
just i was just something came over me
at like a
demonic forces i guess you know and i
started going crazy
and and now people would look out for me
they said no no no no
put your clothes back on and i was just
like really depressed you know just
really like depressed and uh one time i
tried to jump off
the 101 and angel saved me believe it or
not
an angel saved me i try to i try to i
said this is the only way that i'm gonna
die
it has to be something that is gonna be
like uh did you try jumping off the
bridge
uh off of the freeway bridge and um
um i got saved by an angel and i said if
i gotta live then
[ __ ] it but i i don't feel like i belong
on earth anymore
i don't feel like um anyone's gonna
if my family didn't love me and
everything
you know because of uh personal issues
that we have between each other
and because we're different you know
if they turn their back on me i don't
have anyone
i don't have anyone so who's gonna who's
gonna take care of me you know and
i'm gonna get old one day and i don't
have skill
i even i even tried i've worked before i
when i was 16 i worked at coastal you
know coastal
the bestest ice cream ever i went to
cold stone but
i couldn't uh like i i got like mental
difficulties like i don't know
and i couldn't work the register or
anything
and what do you do for money now yeah
what do you do for money now
i panhandle i gotta decide but i don't
have i wasn't staying in a a
rehab but um they were always
uh really we have we have to work we
have to get up at 6 30
and get in and uh and go to sleep at 8
30 so it was like you know
we had a schedule we were like you know
we we had a program going on and i said
this is like prison man i've been to
prison six years
and uh for burglary santa monica i
i took a bad deal you know but i i i
took a bad deal when it was only two
years
but i had so many so many problems with
the with the with the women in the in in
prison and the seals
and everything that i always got not
charged i always got naturals
until accumulated to six years
does shame him play a part in your life
does shame
play a part in your life shame yeah
uh i don't think so because um
i i i'm mentally you know like
um uh i i'm i'm different
at just i'm a woman i'm i need i need
help i need um
i i need family i don't have family no
more
uh you feel like you're just on your own
yeah yeah yeah do you have any friends
now i i think i need friends now you
know i think i need connects you know
do you have any friends now no i have
any friends i don't have any friends
after prison everything changed my
family
finally came to true cutters we don't
want to help you anymore
um they told me a whole lot of things
like you know
like we hate you we don't want to do you
know more we don't want to help you
anymore
and i accepted that it's okay i cried
and everything i cried
i prayed and uh
i died a lot in prison man
how old are you now um i'm 34 i'm still
uh you know i'm still young you know i'm
just so dirty you know
so your father who had alcohol yeah
problems how
how did his life go ah did he get clean
did he
uh i pray for him to get clean and
everything but he's
he's kind of like me we like to be on
our own i like to be on my own
so he's still drinking as far as you
know uh i don't think he was drinking
anymore i
ate after um i think one
what he decided to quit and then he just
quit
he just quit and i was proud of him you
know and um
even when my family kicked me out before
i went to prison like we were roommates
he took care of me
but he would just feed me alcohol
alcohol
alcohol what do you think it would take
for you to
that would make you want to quit um
i'm not gonna lie i will just say this i
don't want to stop drinking
because believe it or not i'm not i'm
not a wild person
i'm not a violent person i don't bother
anyone
i'm just calm when i drink and i feel
i feel like um like i become somebody
else like i don't know like i
they told me this is my one of my
bestest friends is uh
betty berry betty enriquez and um
she likes to do witchcraft she always
took me to the to rojo you know to the
shamanis and everything and she said
girl you gotta believe in this you gotta
believe in this
you go you're to believe in this you're
going to believe in this eh
i said no i don't believe in nothing but
maybe i should you know
and um
we used to drink man we used to drink
and cry
and eat and cry and we don't want to
we don't want to be this way excuse me
and um she she she did me a little dirty
and she worked on me and everything
um uh but um
uh i forgot what i was saying so you you
just
are you happy you seem fairly happy
uh i'm not
happy because i i don't see why
sometimes i want to die i'm still
getting back to someone to a suicidal
thing
because i'm in a lot of pain physical
pain like i hit by two cars
i jumped off a building i got surgery on
my knee and
my wrist my health
isn't so good for being just 34.
in prison i got a heart attack fighting
somebody
yeah i got really i got a real bad heart
attack whenever i was
trying to fight somebody for a [ __ ]
book can you believe that from my own
book
yeah and it was ridiculous but i still
knocked that [ __ ]
what was the worst part of your life
what was the worst
the worst part of my life is when my
family told me
we and we don't want to we don't want
you
we don't want to help you and
we hate you and
they told me they sacrificed me
and you believe in magic
people believe in in god
and demons
illuminati and um
i guess i was ultimately sacrificing
they hate me
uh and this is this is the way
and this is the way i live but i i just
i just
i i like i like being alone a lot i i
always
isolated you know i always um because uh
i don't have secrets i'm open book
but um
i don't i i just are there others in
your family that have
similar they told me the same thing
problems with alcohol
uh just my cousin but he passed away
recovery
i passed away to colerain when i was in
prison
yeah yeah he passed away he's my he's
like my favorite cousin
i passed a little bit and everything
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
in your life
[Music]
the most important is never quit
never quit never quit never quit
you still hope i still have hope even
though i get sad you know
um that's why i think i'm possessed you
know because
i'm not because they did tell me i was a
cyber sacrifice
in other words but i knew it and
i i've started to have doubts because
um i say god
i pray to you and i bound down to you
welcome you know help
and i start getting sad it's the same
maybe because i'm not all like maybe
maybe because
i'm not too smart maybe these people
don't like me
maybe because i'm weird maybe because
i'm poor
maybe because i'm not too pretty and
things like that
you know but can i help those things no
i can help those things
oh whatever i'm gonna go for it
all right ingrid well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you mark
i wish you the best of luck oh you too
man be careful out there
all right always
we gotta eat some food really you can't
just be drinking
this is your first nervousness